so 9 is the boss villain of the new my
hero academia movie that just came out
in Japan and for months we've been
speculating about what his quirks
actually are so today I thought I'd do a
quick video examining the leaks that are
coming out the movie doesn't actually
release in the Western world till 2020
so if you want to go into it completely
blind then just subscribe and check out
some other videos on my channel but for
the rest of you who were like me and
just can't help yourself let's get into
9 squirts and how he has so many
according to the leaks this character
used to be very ill and as a result he
offered up his body to be experimented
on by the League of villains with dr.
Jack O'Neill aiding his body so that he
would be capable of holding 9 quirks but
the downside is that the more quirks he
has the more of a negative impact it has
on his body to start with you might have
guessed from the trailers but his
primary quirk is weather control and
from what I've read is one of the most
versatile quirks that I've ever heard of
he can use it to conjure up massive
lightning strikes and then pinpoint
those strikes on a single person or just
use it to strike everywhere around him
the quirk also enables him to create
storms which is said to be strong enough
to destroy a city and while it isn't
mentioned in the leaks if he can control
the weather then it'd probably be safe
to assume that he could do other stuff
as well like conjuring up hailstones to
hit specific people but that's just me
completely speculating his next quirk is
so reminiscent of Dragon Ball like it's
not even funny
9 apparently has some kind of special
vision that allows him to scan people
and ascertain their exact work and how
powerful they are and this is what he
uses to identify people whose quirk he
wants to take he can also use this power
to see through illusions and kind of
like visual tricks we might have seen
this special vision in the trailers when
he has those red eyes now brace yourself
for this next quirk because it's pretty
ridiculous but it has been confirmed
from several different leaks that I've
read so I do actually think it's true 9
can create something that from all
reports is a blue-eyes White Dragon yes
you did indeed hear that right similar
to how toki army conjures up dark shadow
9 can conjure up blue-eyes White Dragons
and apparently he can do more than one
at the same time I mean where do you
even begin with a quirk like this is I
mean it's pretty cool if you're finding
a large group it's pretty handy to have
an army of dragons at your disposal but
it is definitely more Supernatural than
some of the powers were used to and his
fourth quirk is definitely
the one we've seen the most of if you've
watched all the trailers he can shoot
lasers out of each of his fingers at
once and these lasers are said to be
powerful enough to completely destroy
houses like burn them to the ground so
I'd imagine that if it hit a human being
it'd be like a one shot one kill kind of
thing unless that person is literally
made of steel which does happen the fact
he can shoot lasers from each individual
finger means that he can cover a really
wide area and make it pretty hard to
avoid similar to the blue-eyes White
Dragon one is pretty good for like
taking out large groups of people and as
if all that wasn't enough ix has a fifth
quirk that essentially allows him to
create barriers which look really
similar to dr. Strange's ones like if
you put him side by side come on now we
can see here that one barrier is strong
enough to hold back one for all with
relative ease like he doesn't look like
he's straining himself or anything he
can put up multiple barriers at the same
time that can shield him from virtually
any direction and this is 100% a useful
quirk to have but I feel like 10 guys
quirk from the anime recently is
probably a bit better because you can
like use it once and it covers your
whole body whereas from the sounds of 9
squirt he actually has to think about
where he needs to put them 9 uses this
barrier in conjunction with another
quirk and this quote generates wind that
prevents people from reaching him and if
this is accurate it sounds not too
dissimilar from eNOS as wind quirk as
you can see we kind of reached the point
in my hero academia where there are just
so many quirks that a lot of them are
bound to be either the same or very
similar that said you can still get
pretty original ones I mean I still
can't believe this now 9s next quirk is
a bit of a dud this quirk allows you to
regenerate cells which would be good but
the problem is that it only works on a
certain blood type which 9 doesn't
actually have and there's not really
much else to say about it
other than he should give it back to
whoever he took it from like there's no
need for you to still have that bro as
four nines remaining quirks it's a bit
ambiguous we obviously know that he can
steal other people's quirks and this is
likely his eighth power but from the
leaks it's unclear whether it's the suit
he's wearing that steals the quirks or
whether it's an actual quote that he has
as someone who hasn't seen the movie I
can't confirm it either way all we know
is that he can steal quirks and he does
this by grabbing people in the face and
absorbing their power this is obviously
exactly how often one used to do it
which begs the question how did you JUCO
copy the awful one quark and give it to
this random guy
like if nine can get it then no doubt
sugar aki is gonna get it very soon and
from the basic plot of this movie it
seems like nine is motivated to try and
acquire another quark which would then
give him nine if he was to get it but
it's unclear whether his body can
surpass the limit of nine as we see in
the trailer that he grabs deku with the
intent to take one for all what
essentially I'm trying to say is that if
his maximum amount of quirks is nine and
he already has eight and he desperately
needs another one then I doubt he would
try and steal one for all so I'm
guessing he can surpass the limit of
nine but whatever the situation I'll
definitely be seeing this when it comes
out in the UK in 2020 and I hope you
enjoyed this quick breakdown of what 9s
quarks are I have another video plan
this week where I'm going to talk about
the future of miryo tagata
but until then peace
you